this the whole podcast the whole time
whole time the whole time down well
thanks jibber jabber oh my goodness this
is the new show now everyone this is the
weekly poll funny voices Edition what I
don't know what you're talking about
fuing weird I I can't tell if that's
more jar jar than anything Misa Benny
Misa host of the showa oide right I
finally watched the Star Wars movies
finally you did yeah then I haven't seen
the force awakens yet wait wow
welcome to the weekly poll I've been
around gone forever but we are now at
the intro I'm Betty the comic story and
that is s from comic poop that is Joel
The Capes Joel the only thing that
matters it's his important project it's
the only thing he does that we give a
[__] about totally starting problems for
you it's going to be funny yeah that's
nice that's nice Benny thanks for
putting just threw it out there man you
see that bus you underneath it that's
Rob from Comics explained and that is f
from it's super effective F and our
buddies we're going to do a bunch bun of
selfies at Wonder con we're super
besties now that's exactly what we are I
want to see some by the way back to Joel
only thing that matters his appearance
like on nerd sync comic TV and Cape Joel
[__] everything else [__] it [__] it all
wow he said that he Benny is just saying
Joel's exact words
soe is the bus crushing me right now
that I you guys want drama [__] everyone
it is
drama you know what you know what while
we're at it I hate everyone let's Rob
how do you feel about cbir 19 hey let's
talk about variant Comics let's talk
about nerdsync hey how's Goldman doing
everybody just leaves the show it just
it just becomes a sea of blank faces and
Benny see I see I like everyone so just
everyone out there it's funny because I
do like them all but it's funnier if you
act like you don't yeah no cuz I've
worked with kber 19 we worked with
variant but [__] them are we are we
doing the rapper thing now are we trying
to start feuds we're trying to start
blood feuds on the internet now to drive
up viewers you know what you know what
yeah it's exactly what we're doing but
you know what we actually do like comic
grow very varant we like all of them so
I'm only playing around you know what we
don't like comic book
cast wow man you're just throwing it out
there wow true it's
true oh look oh look my email is
exploding right now how did that happen
oh my God Twitter's blowing
up when views expressed by Benny do not
ultimately reflect all the views of
everyone Untouchable this is what
happens to your show you know you know
why you know why I hate Comic Book cast
you know why because I went to New York
Comic Con he didn't even say hi boom
what boom bombs Dro that's what happens
Man In fairness he didn't know you were
there but whatever I mean if he's got
Twitter he knew you know what if DC
could reboot every week so in the weekly
poll [__] everything yeah
yeah welcome to the first episode all
new all different all new all different
every episode is me and drag so we
suddenly have from the did you guys miss
me did you miss me did you [__] miss
me it's the weekly it's week weekly pool
Weir that's what it is the R-rated years
of the weekly poll shots fired
yeah so many shots okay okay so so the
first order of business for today no
hold on hold on before we get to that I
just want to say I was at the red last
night and you knew who was it comic book
cat God damn it man it's going to be a
running gag of the whole show every
couple of minutes I get to put up with
this [__] all weekend
yay I would like you guys were just
watching Rob and I are going to be at
pack South this weekend doing panels and
signings oh my God you know who won't be
Joel say it Joel I'm cool with them
everything's fine everything's cool well
okay the good thing the good thing is
that Natalie's going to be there so at
least somebody will keep B [__] like you
could man Club can't hold him back I'm
just I'm just I'm just saying man you
know I mean I'm not sorry Fame is going
to my head I got to walk the red carpet
with Chris Pine uh AKA Colonel Trevor
I'm not uh I'm not I'm not calling Benny
out or anything I'm just saying that you
know when we were in uh
La yeah we were in La Natalie was like
Ben you need to shut up and like Benny
shut up so you know I'm just yeah no
Natalie's awesome she's definitely like
you guys suck whatever I'm just saying
man I'm just I'm just throwing it out
I'm just throwing it out there okay so
anyway so anyway first order first order
of business first order of business is
uh DC rebirth which we got to we got to
talk about start with the biggest thing
possible the biggest thing possible that
also we don't know is yet that we also
don't know anything about okay did I
thought yeah but Lally but everyone
keeps coming to all of us and like you
heard DC's rebooting They're bringing
back the old continuity they're starting
from the beginning of the new 52 it's
like where did you find all of this out
that's what I'm saying I've seen the
exact same rumors like oh it's it's a
restarting it's like rebirth for all we
know that's just convergence 2.0 like
for all we know it's one book for all we
know it's like a
flash there were Rumblings it could be
anything it could literally be a Green
Lantern event it's not like we don't
know that it's a like it's an entire
reshuffling of the catalog like we just
know that we just know there's a stupid
crappy Photoshop curtain and the hash
rebirth which for all we know could be
Superman rebirth coming back he said
flash rebirth it could be anything it
could be anything all maybe maybe
rebirth is their number 50s the Superman
and Batman return yeah no no no like
what what they're doing is as far as I
understand it the the only information
that we have is that rebirth picks up
after the 52nd issue of all the comics
oh God like once the 52 issues put that
together then it becomes what is with
obsession with that number I don't know
man it's like Harry Potter it's like
Harry Potter in the magic number seven
dude it's s who specifically likes that
number while he's at DC we have loads of
it starts with 52 weeks in a year and
they start with that and then it just
spilled over into 52 like no but the 52
places in the Multiverse worlds 52 books
52 title like no I think it was
originally because the new 52s started
with 52 books because originally it was
supposed to happen at the end of 52
weeks right and then and then they just
never changed it
for
yeah crisis New 52 now it's F this is
rebirth which is coming on the heels of
DCU which lasted a little under a year
and I mean DCU really just consisted of
Jim Goron the bat Mech and Wonder Woman
god of war and power Le power Superman
like here's what I think it's GNA be and
aqua bro which are all coming to an end
yeah maybe no I I can tell exactly what
it's probably going to be it's probably
something they' honestly have planned
for quite some time I don't think it's
going to be a new universe I don't think
it's going to be a fresh reboot of the
continuity nothing I have a feeling
issue 52 is going to end a whole bunch
of things and rebirth is a brand new
slew of number ones which is always the
way they go because apparently no comic
can reach a hundred anymore well that's
old that means that they're like
geriatric you forget
it no I mean that that makes that makes
sense to me though I mean because you
got to think about it you got think
about it this way you know I mean new 52
did good at first you know and then
there were a handful of titles did well
I think a lot of the titles didn't do as
well and of course that was with DCU
where they canceled a bunch of stuff and
then DCU didn't have the reception they
were looking for and so it makes sense
to me that they
considerably during the DC and it it
would make sense to me that they would
come back and and honestly I would I'd
capitalize on what byy said and not only
is it going to be new number ones like
we're gonna see some old stuff coming
back I mean like you've got Superman
Lois and Clark like I think we're gonna
see some free flasho Superman you got
Superman Lois and Clark and you also
have Titans hunt which are two huge
examples of characters remembering stuff
from the old continuity and the old
universes that still happened I mean
especially if Titans hunt heavily
heavily implying that they're going to
be bringing back the old Wally West like
like there's just the word Flash the
fact of the matter is as much as
everyone wants like all the classic fans
want new 52 gone Lois and Clark and
Titans s are the great examples why
would they just now launch these story
lines to get rid of them six months
later now it's not unheard of for them
to do such a thing no it's true they do
that but but it is it does seem like an
extreme thing to be like oh look some of
your old heroes are still here oh you
know what [__] that we're just starting
over well because it would be it would
be test bed stuff I mean right now like
you've got everything that exists right
now is is effectively New 52 stuff and
then everything is just kind of other
stuff that's there like if you come back
and you say this is DC rebirth and New
52 DCU none of that matters anymore and
it's just a singular continuity then now
it's no longer you've got New 52
Superman and then you've got pre- flash
point Superman it's just you've got two
Superman living in the same continuity
and the stories would unfold accordingly
I can tell I
I'm telling you right now rebirth is
just going to be a fresh number ones cuz
think about it in one to two months
every book is going to hit 50 The Return
of Superman and Batman oh look there's
this big movie uh maybe you've heard of
it it's called Batman versus Superman
coming out at the same time they're
going 50 is going to be brand new that's
the rebirth it'll be they might because
you know what they did they tag lined
everything new 52 then they got rid of
that maybe they're going to tag them
rebirth number one you know like maybe
that's the whole thing so you know this
is the return of our characters's
I mean would they do it for all of their
titles or just select titles this time
that would be that would make sense I
think they're gonna select because a lot
of books suffered from DCU I don't know
I mean I mean think about it this way go
ahead I'm sorry sorry the top the top
seven titles will get the rebirth and
then the rest will not you know like
just they'll just say like oh they're
part of it or they're not depends on how
we'd feel about the Creator we're
working with if they're ingrained they
don't have to worry about it if they're
new [__] them they got to fold in line
you know but like otherwise it's just
going to be you know like flash green
lter Superman Batman one moment like
those Justice League those are the books
that'll get rebirthed and the rest of
them you know whatever and because
knowing DC they'll just be like well
we'll just we'll just figure it out
afterwards like just do the ones that
sell and then we'll just make the other
ones like whatever like Constantine I
don't know does do people want that like
all right the Hell Blazer
yeah I mean there are a lot of
characters that people want but they
don't want how DC are doing them at the
moment and I kind of do hope that that
kind of fixes situ like Constantine is a
great example of that he
is really I was thinking that I was
thinking about that I I say me to say it
I'm sorry the English pronunciation it's
fine is it chesher or Cheshire you tell
me is it was it F it's not the it's not
the sh of chesh it's cheser the sh of
ches that's an argument I've had so much
is it Cheshire or chesher the fact of
matter is with this rebirth this
discussion though they've literally just
teased the image it's the exact same
thing as the Justice League teaser image
that everyone's like where's Green
Lantern we don't know like we all have
that behind theen there's also a lot of
rumors going around too about with new
number ones will also come reshuffled
writing teams there was a big rumor
going around there that Snyder might be
going back to Detective Comics and make
that a Powerhouse book now where before
it was just kind of always an also ran
Batman book where it's like Batman and
Detective Comics if you want to read it
maybe Capo pretty much confirmed it what
today or yesterday that Snider's
definitely gonna be going to detective
and he might go too after the after SN
and capilo work on something else
together yeah because Cap's gone for
sure after no gapul is supposedly not
unless they change it not working with
Snider he wants to take a break from him
that's I I remember seen the interview
where they were breaking up and he's
like no honestly Snider's getting all
the fame and Greg capula wants to put
his name on some other stuff well and he
wants to draw some stuff that's not
Batman for a little Fair yeah that said
he does he does draw mean Batman he
draws a really mean
Batman can I just say like when SNY does
go to to detective and detective
suddenly becomes a huge an even bigger
book than it already is um I hope that
jock goes with him oh that'd be cool
that would be good I mean just like just
Black Mirror the crap yes people forget
that that Snyder became a household name
or started to off the back of a
Detective comic story Black Mirror which
was him and jock and it was Dick Grace
and his Batman it was freaking great
that was detective yes it was cuz I've
only I only know it now as Batman Black
Mirror like it's it was a collection of
detective stories and
the God my main hope for detective is
that as much as Everyone likes Batman on
the book my favorite runs of detective
are not Batman on the book um like my
all time favorite run of Detective
Comics is Batwoman so I that's real good
yeah so I just hope that we have you
know sort of a break from Batman because
he's gonna be [__] everywhere like if
if SNY does do detective I hope they
keep Batman the superhero book and I
hope Detective Comics is the mystery
book as the way it should always be
Apparently one of the one of the
interviews that I read recently talked
about um kind of like Batman the
adjective less title being more event
driven and to step away from that which
means we'll probably get more isolated
selfcontained yeah one and duns are two
two to three parters where it's just
Batman dealing with a problem and using
his detective skills to solve I would
like
that half not like the entire city being
threatened every every single time from
a hell mouth about to open up and suck
up the whole city and I've been saying
this since like about 2 years after the
New 52 if I lived in Gotham I'd move to
foret City because foret seems to be
really quiet yeah yeah shazam's got that
[__] under control if it's not owls it's
Jokers if it's not Jokers it's crazy or
whatever they're supposed to it's
totally Bloom is so slender man I'll be
honest man like I like I love Snider's
Batman like it was it was such a great
story but it got to a point where I was
like man I mean you know I'm ready to
see just like a villain of the week like
just some just some guy who's like you
know what I'm going to go rob this bank
and Batman's like no you're not story
some of those stories have done that if
you read detective um I think the last
detective was Jim Gordon Batman doing a
solo single Mission no I'm not talking
I'm talking about well I mean I know you
don't like I'm saying is that they've
been doing these like solo missions and
stuff like that matter of fact I know
you guys are saying that now um but
Detective Comics actually just had right
before they brought in Robo Batman did a
story about Anarchy and it was totally
solo stand alone yeah I will say this
how about Europa Europa is a great
standal story going I Haven I haven't
read that many it's it's not even
connected with continuity you got to
read Europa Rob Europa it's one issue
left to being done and it's it's already
probably one of the best Batman stories
ever it's Batman and Joker having to
team up that's the whole plot the
only every is different artist it's a
European road trip with Batman and the
Joker dude I will I will definitely
check it out they're both infected you
find out their first issue like right
right off the bat but they're both
infected with the same virus and it's
going to kill them in 24 hours so they
have to team up and figure out what the
hell's going on they go to France Rome
and Berlin I still think the best line
ever was Joker asking Batman when is he
going to get his own pair of
tights that sounds pretty awesome or the
fact that the sicker Batman gets his
vision starts to degrade and so the art
in the book gets weirder and trippier
and everything going on with that
because I wasn't tracking okay oh okay
well that's that's actually really cool
that's really and even the villain I
won't spoil the villain but he's he's
called Trojan Horse and we actually get
to see what his deal is I'm like oh
that's an interesting
deal really that's what you're all about
like I I will say this like like I guess
you know kind of backtracking with the
whole um the whole Jim Gordon Batman
thing he's actually he's actually not
that bad like I think that like a lot of
people were kind of giving a crap like I
mean I'm ready for Bruce Wayne to come
back but a lot of people were just kind
of like man like Jim Gordon Batman sucks
like I don't think he's that bad like I
think the cool thing about Jim Gordon
Batman is he was a guy who was woefully
unprepared for the role like just
stepped into I kind of wish that they
explored that aspect a little more and
maybe they are in the peripheral titles
but in the core Batman book it's just
Gordon dealing with one insurmountable
problem after another and you get that
in detective a little bit cuz detective
basically just became like a Gotham
Central book because Renee Montoya came
back and he got to hang out with bulock
again it's just like no I'm a I'm a
Batman who plays by the rules and helps
the cops is what I do and
that's I the record I just tweeted out
that you are officially my replacement
as I get busier and bus your Joel oh am
I okay cool that works
I okay so what what's our uh what's our
next J Jones season 2 unless unless you
got something you want to say I want to
add something to the to the roster of
conversation since we talked about
rebirth we should also talk about dead
no more Ah that's the Marvel rebirth mic
drop teaser as well dead no more yeah
it's just it's just dead no more Marvel
and oh oh oh yeah okay okay I thought
you talking about like a Deadpool thing
you they like to each other and they're
like you're doing rebirth okay we'll do
something like that too but right no
one's supposed to know that we we we
both know uh word that kind of sounds
like rebirth oh dead no more no you know
what dead no more is I can guarantee you
that's that's like either it's either
it's going to be like Charles Xavier
wolver rain like a handful of those
people coming back like I could almost
guarantee that what's the point of
bringing back Wolverine right now when
we're getting an Old Man Logan book and
we already have an X2 because old man
Logan's not Wolverine no cool though
they are very quickly making Old Man
Logan Wolverine though you think so you
not notice that yeah yeah I've noticed
that but like within the first issue
he's like no I'm Old Man Logan I've
killed people I can't do this and
they're like oh we'll give you another
shot basically as much as and as much as
I'm liking Laura as Wolverine she is
gradually turning in to Logan with boobs
very very slowly which I'm not gonna lie
I have nothing
against I'm not I like x23 before but
her being Logan with boobs I'm kind of
on board with
oh doing amazing job with that
book's costume really looks better on a
woman hold on hold on hold on hold on
think about this let's let's think about
this for a second let's let's let's
let's think about this for a second you
okay there what did what did uh what did
uh Owen Reese do for Miles Morales
brought his mom back he brought his mom
back what if he brought back everyone's
moms get what what if they wrote it
where like he brought back GW Stacy oh
dude like the original two other
ones we have you don't have the real one
and there's there's a distinct
difference between the boring killable
Gwen Daisy have
replaceable 30 years Dead character Gwen
Stacy what's Stacy's biggest problem
she's killable yeah I love GW Stacy but
she's also like she wasn't even relevant
or interesting until uh Jeff L and Tim s
did a really good book about her and
even after that they like she was it was
Spider-Man blue but then afterwards
she's still better as a dead character
than alive one like she's it says a lot
about a character when the most
important thing they've done is die
right unless you're talking about
ultimate Gwen Stacy who it's like they
should never have killed her and Ben as
a me like immediately recognized that
and then Rond her into a Carnage clone
like that or Bucky or Bucky too there's
another character who he said forever
should you know have remained dead until
he came back and was kind of awesome
Baker is like you know what let's BR
back Bucky Barnes because you know what
hell of a pitch by the way but like I I
I'm hoping dead no more is they bring
everyone back everyone who's ever died
like any character any any superhero
that's ever died just bring them like a
bright as day kind of
situation I see I see where you're
coming from but um the planets only got
so much space on it I mean really and
there's no multi well no there's
multiple Earths now that the Fantastic
Four whipping up universes left and
right plus the X-Men are in purgatory or
we world or whatever so they can there's
some they're going to world now oh
that's right they are I read that
solicitation pretty cool okay let me ask
you guys this real quick why do you
think they're bringing back weird world
so goddamn hardcore I don't
know it's a gorgeous book like I don't
know about the reboot one but the secret
Wars one by delmundo is so cool looking
love me some Delo who but who is asking
for a Conan Marvel Universe I don't know
saying I'm in but like I don't who is
Jason Aaron still writing the ongoing
like he was writing the mini I don't
remember I have to like well the chat
chatt world are answered for us but like
for the for the mo for right now we'll
just say Yes uh till they change our
minds I was gonna say usually if Aaron
writes it it turns to Gold the dude has
like a really good sort of thing like
people buy his books on name yeah solid
track record people usually buy his
books on name alone yeah yeah it's
true I know I anyway dead no more Bo I
mean if it's if it's Spider-Man related
like GW Gwen Stacy or like Uncle Ben are
the only characters I can think of
spiderverse they both they literally
made a a clothing merchandising machine
out of Gwen Stacy and a boring who gives
a crap out of Uncle Ben and put him in
the mc2 universe and they wrote him a
happy ending where he got to live no
he's back now do you guys not reading
web warriors no no I sto and Mayday are
both back uh they're the basically the
web warri is having problems so they
went to go get them okay oh wow so now
they're in the books yeah oh that's
that's right oh no no Uncle Ben took
Benji at the end of spider I'm saying
they went to to that world where there's
Mayday and Uncle really you know like
that's kind of like a what the hell took
them so long to get Mayday onto the way
the web warriors like crap took them
that long because she's you immediately
sell however many Spider Girl fans there
are amount of books and she sells enough
books at least to Warrant her re her
title being resurrected twice and you
know somewhere and Somewhere Out There
Kane fans are all crying they're like
when's it time dud I'm looking at is it
Kane back now he survived spiderverse
but they haven't actually used him yet
because they're using everyone Miguel
o'hare's got a book freaking spidergwen
got a book like spider got he had a book
he had a book but no one bought it so
dude I actually loved his book about him
in Houston and going into the spider
toems I totally got in I was like
totally on board it was a really cool
looking book The Art was a little
inconsistent for me because I wanted to
see Stegman just do that book but
otherwise solid title they canceled it
then they tried to fold him into new
Warriors that book was unreadable
canceled that moved on oh no new
Warriors is horrible horrible I mean not
not to begrudge new Warriors fans but
like that was and I love continuity
right I'm a continuity buff I love those
those that like all the history and crap
and in new Warriors book they've been
around for 30 years you got you have a
lot of stories to tell they went to
wonder Gore Mountain crap it was so
bogged down by just needless crap and
now Nova gets to be an AV and they put
it and they put him in there like and
the the reason they put SP Spider-Man
like Scarlet Spider in there made no
sense
it was like when they put Supergirl into
the Justice League Unlimited it was like
she was there she was literally there as
a cameo character and that's that's what
Kane was in that book I didn't think
because the writer wrote scarl spider
and then his book got canceled so he's
like well I'm writing Warriors I'll put
him in there yeah exactly yeah and they
a couple of his plot lines but but yeah
no I mean everyone's got a book right
now and I'm actually I'm actually liking
all the spider books yeah um the only
complaint I have right now is the main
spider book Amazing Spider-Man is like
going nowhere like great and I could
know he's setting up for a whole bunch
of crap but it's like come on dude give
me some I think going by monthly really
hurt that book and a couple books that
go by monthly because it's like ah this
feels like half a story you wrote me
right here let me tell you something I
don't give a rat's ass about those
zodiac gang ah they're not there and I
don't give a crap about Doc O being
trapped in a robot body for like 12 more
issues what about Norman Osborne being
hush or yeah nor being hush he's not
crazy anymore listen if you if you
maniacally build a base in the sewers
and have your face changed and like
concoct world domination plans you're
still crazy so sorry that's not that's
not a plot point for me but what about
the mysterious dude in red who is almost
certainly Satan or Mesto going around
and recruiting members of the Sinister 6
to join him don't give a crap about at
all it's so boring I dropped that book
three issues ago I'm like I don't I
don't give a crap about anything that's
happening here Spider-Man with his I
can't I can do anything car and anyway
it's the spider mobile which really
pissed off Johnny Storm that he remade
it it did that was actually pretty funny
in the middle in the middle of their
fight mobile without me yeah that fight
was literally every superhero crossover
you ever seen in your life where it's
when pages of misunderstanding that
could be solved in half a sentence and
then two pages of oh we're friends again
yay but a sweet ending cuz Peter Built a
statue of the Fantastic was such a great
and we're I'm going to keep your home
safe until you can come home until Fox
let's you go yeah until Fox I'm Gonna
Keep your building safe I like that I
love that idea I when I heard the
premise of Park is bought the backer
building I'm like [__] yeah that's
awesome they didn't do anything
interesting with
that I mean what's he gonna do just like
like build a statue of himself in the
back building that would be awesome
that's that's okay I'm sure Peter will
pry up a floor board and find like
Johnny Storm's secret stash under or
something where it's
like
from hey those are collector's items you
could sell those yeah okay so let's
let's roll is there any more books to
really just dive into right now I mean
DC is not doing anything major at the
moment I can't think of scarlet wit oh
yeah yeah Captain America's back that's
right Captain he's not back yet they've
announced that he will conveniently in
day just time for his but here's the
thing the book is going to be called
Steve Rogers captain America we're still
going to have Sam Wilson Captain America
so you're going to have two Captain
America books going on at the same time
with two different guys which I think
Honesty though they've set up for that
though if you've been reading if you've
been reading Sam Wilson he's all about
doing with his own image and his own
that's that's where we're gonna go
that's that's he's gonna break away and
then he's gonna get the super Sy back
and he's Steve Rogers is gonna be like
well since you're doing this for the
world I'm Captain America and if you've
checked out the solicitations for Sam
Wilson uh you see in an upcoming issue I
think it's like is n or something it's
him Steve Rogers and Bucky back in a
Captain America costume doing some sort
of mission together I'm like oh dude the
three CS that is
fun oh the uh I can't pronounce that
username there though but uncanny and
humans I'm actually oh dude it was
really good yeah yeah I'm liking that
too that's the black ho one right
because there's the other one that I
don't like and I'm surprised I'm
surprised how well they're doing with it
to be honest like I I thought it was
just going to I I know they're trying to
push it but I thought it was going to be
one of those things where they're like
we're more concerned about just getting
books out there than like making good
books and it's actually pretty solid
Charles Soul Man Charles soul and I and
I actually like the all new in humans
book I like that it's a globe trotting
book I like honestly it feels like
Classic X-Men is what it feels like well
I mean Al how you how you holding up
over there buddy I but I will say that
book I mean I was saying that with
Charles Soul's uh in like his his
inhuman was it inhuman or inhumanity the
one before inum before that his his
inhuman run like it felt like X-Men it
felt like a classic Claremont X-Men and
so like I'm I'm really happy with with
what they're doing with that I me it's
it's all well and good that the Inhumans
are feeling like X-Men but like can the
X-Men feel like X-Men I me right
because has been an I am loving every
minute of extraordinary X-Men I like it
too that first Arc was incredible it was
fun I I like pretty good but it was good
I liked it but extraordinary was like
this is the [__] X-Men finally
extraordinary is that is the Premier
X-Men
book it's the flagship uncanny is cool
too uncanny has had two issues I like it
because you get to hang out with Magneto
and Sabertooth and you know it's fun
writing it so hav't actually gone too
yet I haven't uncanny is okay uncanny
has that problem that a lot of these
books that have gone by monthly have
where I'm like I feel like you gave me
half a story here I just want fun back
into my
Xmen s old Old Man Logan and Jean going
back and forth that you know jokes being
peppered in finally storm being in
charge but also trying to fix the whole
thing I mean the book's just great I
love it I I would recommend all new to
you f because it's on the younger
characters they're having a road trip
yeah I've been reading all new but it's
just like I don't for me my highlight of
like I think everyone's got like one
time period where they really sort of
associate this is the definitive X-Men
for me personally and for me it's
2004 or three when Marvel were doing the
tsunami imprint and they had uh new
X-Men Academy X and it was just so Grant
Morrison your it's not Grant Morrison oh
okay it's like X-Men is but not Academy
x no not Academy X it was like it was it
was like Teenage X-Men in the school and
it was like a homeless girl that ended
up being a mutant and and they wrote it
as if it was a manga and it was great
have you been reading worst X-Men
ever uh I've got it I haven't read it
yet cuz I I I think you'll like it I
think it's worst X-Man ever I've never
it's a new digital book worst X-Men ever
okay it's kind of fun I have to check
that out that sounds like awesome what
do you guys think about uncanny Avengers
cuz that just wrapped up too oh oh my
God yeah it was fun don't give a crap
about that book I I I don't like that
cable hijacked the last little bit of it
cuz I was all excited to meet this new
team and see how they work together like
well here go cable to save the day I
thought I thought it was exciting I was
I love that last page reveal of cable
just being like hey guess what 90s [__]
and you're like okay yeah I mean here's
here's the problem that I that I have
like I I love cable and and and with C
with Deadpool being in there I was
really hoping we'd see some cable and
Deadpool action which was cool to see
get a little of it with yeah with them
you know kind of messing around and
stuff like that you know I just kind of
felt like like a cable was just kind of
forced in there it kind of cuts the
knees off of this new team where it's
like hey new team you couldn't save the
world you couldn't solve the problem
cable had to come back in time and clean
up your mess and clean Yeah clean it
they couldn't even solve the damn
problem they're so ineffective I
actually didn't mind The Uncanny
Avengers like it's not greatest thing
ever but but I didn't mind it my problem
with The Uncanny Avengers is that it was
promoted as being the team book with
Spider-Man and Deadpool was the first
like three pages he's out and they have
a separate book for that Adventure yes
now I bet you money that the plan was it
was going to be Spider-Man Spider-Man
Deadpool in the Avengers and then
someone said wait a minute why don't we
have our cake and eat it too a
Spider-Man Deadpool book and then take
these D listers and make him do stuff
and I'm not a big Quicksilver and his
friends but who gives a crap the point
is is cool and I don't think they're
going to get Rogue anywhere else right
now I want I want 90s Rogue I want like
superpowered Rogue who's just like oh my
powers like I just want that I don't
want like I'm the last one now I can't
even have babies I can't even get laid
but now I won't even be able to have
babies this is bull shut up okay I'm put
I would do rogue even if it would kill
me she's like oh c I die happily I
wouldn't but that's kind of obv that
another reason that has nothing to do
with Rogue yeah oh it is I mean somebody
somebody sent me a picture on Twitter it
was a scene from X-Men the Animated
Series where like apocalypse is like
attacking Rogue and like she's laying
down on the ground and it just has a c
just says dead ass really really really
fans you're not won over by the Majesty
that is brother Voodoo who brother
Voodoo was technically on the last
uncanny Avengers team he did nothing in
that and he did nothing in this new one
too why are you even on the team man
like and he had remember when remember
when Bendis thought he was going to be
the next big thing and made him into the
sorcerer Supreme and then he got his own
freaking book and he did bought it and
then they and then the next Arc was
Bendis giving sorcer Supreme back to
Doctor Strange he's a he's a cool design
I'll give him that much but they've
written very little with him he was a
plot device during
uh whatever the hell when everyone and
whenever was M was sad that Steve Rogers
was dead and uh Iron Man was trying to
like break into the sanum San tour he's
like I got a guy who does magic too do
it brother Voodoo and he's like magic
whammy and then they were like it didn't
work and they're like all right get back
get the hell back in the toy chest
brother
Voodoo where's my Papa Shango book
because that's the thing with you know
brother Voodoo you're that much closer
to a Papa Shango book all right so how
about this one then I'm trying to think
of the ones that ended up arcs New
Avengers that one is like what the hell
is this I'm have not been reading have
not been reading your that's the one
that's the one with Sunfire I haven't
been reading that one at all that's the
one with Sunfire and that's the one with
like every d-lister and squirrel girl I
I couldn't I couldn't I couldn't get
into it okay so wicked like the little
kid Hulk like yeah hulking I was hul so
yeah my characters basically I I like
that you called I the book isn't
horrendous but it's like what the hell
is this no the book isn't horrendous but
the characters aren't the characters
it's like the writer wanted to write
other characters and was told H sorry
you can't have those and he was just
kind of like well what if Squirrel Girl
was not Squirrel Girl and what if wi was
Scarlet Witch I mean that's exactly what
like Wick's considering a name change
because he doesn't want to be named as a
religion and hulkling is now the Prince
of Space or something like that like
I've been reading it I really have
here's the thing with hulkling he
technically is royalty so yes but he's a
yeah all right wi wants a name change
because huling was calling him out for
his name like you can't call yourself
Wiccan that's a religion
yeah but then before he was called
Asgardian and they made fun of him for
being called Asgardian because he's gay
and as guardian what they
just what they just called him what did
they just called him fa what about that
name that's a pretty cool name think we
agree that cast me to play right and
then F could be him you know and then
that would be a lot like how they're
casting Benedict Wong as in strange
movie Benedict Wong will stand next to
Benedict Cumberbatch and play W in the
doctor isn't that weird like there's a
joke in there but I can't make
it a good point though another name I
can't pronounce the maker is in that
book as like
the but yeah I'm I'm gonna be I'm gonna
be honest about that like I really felt
like they kind of squandered the maker
and here's why like evil Reed Richards
is an awesome villain like he's such a
great villain especially well especially
the way Hickman wrote him but whatever
like he is he's a super good villain and
I felt like should have been like a much
more prominent villain instead of just
being resigned to like the the Frat the
Frat Boys like he should have just been
like here's the thing with these
characters these characters are supposed
to be are supposed to be highlighted um
the next generation of the Marvel
Universe like supposedly if they were to
ever kill off all our current a-listers
these are the ones that would be the
next replacement aists obviously they'll
never do that even Hawkeye replacement
if they were allowed to age they would
be but and so like by giving them a
villain like that that isn't supposed to
be seen as squandering it but obviously
they need to be written well and they
are so rarely written well I mean I
think as soon as that book like as soon
as I read the first issue I was like
it's got 12 issues 12 issues at most oh
dude somebody made a look at it this way
here's the problem with Marvel trying to
do this whole thing for almost I want to
say like eight years now they've been
trying to come up with new
Heroes because they know that the
Avengers cast is going to get tiresome
they're trying to make more people
important out of all of these D listers
B listers C listers all these other
superheroes they've made I can think of
two that they've managed to push into
the Limelight that's Miss Marvel and
Nova even Captain Marvel is kind of like
on the C of let me tell you something it
also I feel like the the the the
popularity of uncanon humans like people
are like hey it's great is just because
and it's that I think it's I think
Kamala Khan and Sam Alexander have the
same exact thing and it's not that
they're necessarily great it's that
Marvels like these are the things I want
you to look at and eventually people
were like hey I really like this inhuman
book it's a lot like the thing I
actually like and I I don't think I
don't think people are that if you're if
you're forced into a room and told that
there are three lights when there's
actually four uh eventually there's
going to be four light I I think that's
a not not according
G Wilson and I mean listen nice book and
and and uh I don't care about Nova but
like the new NOA run is amazing Sean
Ryan who wrapped up a great suicide
squad run that not enough people gave
him credit for I'm glad to see him
getting more work I mean the proof in
Marvel just sort of giving you things
that they want you to pay attention to
yeah is in that you don't need to look
and I'm only bringing this up because
I've been I'm doing like three or four
videos about it so pretty soon um is the
the Big Hero 6 movie if Marvel really
wanted you to care about new characters
that they and they would have made
another Big Hero 6 book to go along with
the release of that movie especially
considering the young audience that
movie would have brought him they didn't
do that because they didn't care no they
did so bizarre well the Big Hero 6 book
from 200 they're a manga they have
a releasing manga that's not Marvel it's
different company yeah
still WR out to do it it's been coming
out the movie that's Disney animation
Disney Animation writes it's B Weir as
it sounds in this day and age aren't
kids young kids that that movie was
geared towards more likely to read a
manga book than pick up a traditional
comic book I don't know is becoming a
big thing I don't know if you guys are
aware of this but I'm trying this thing
called manga storian go check out these
videos my channel yeah oh okay um talk
about berserk here here's what I would
say like BK's coming actually that was
oh is it seriously um no here's here's
what I would say like I don't I don't
think people are that cynical man like I
think that that I I'm cynical I don't
think the people are justas duped it's
you're very cynical yeah but I think
that uh it's not that like it's by the
way these it's not like uncanny humans
isn't good I'm just saying that like if
everyone said I don't care about these
Inhumans just make us X-Men and just
said no I'm not going to buy that like
it wouldn't matter how good it was but
the fact is it also like it showed that
Marvel's like okay you can't just push
it in front of you you also have to put
like decent people on it but it is I SS
has been writing it for a long time but
we also know for a fact that a great
book does not guarantee success true and
I think it's just because the machine KN
like you know gain centes and figured
out you got to put decent people behind
something you want them to buy it's why
Force awakened is slightly better you
know for some people slightly and for
most of us much better than the prequels
it's like there's no freaking way a
movie like that can fail but if you make
it decent or good it will be that much
better so it's like you know uncan
humans Kamala Khan Sam Alexander if you
you could you could just if you force
people to look at this stuff for years
eventually people gonna go you know this
a Nova book ain't bad but like at the
same time if you make it actually okay
more people will be like it's not bad
and I have a reason to actually say that
because it's actually pretty good you
know like but it's I I can't pretend
that it's not part of the machine that
wants us to like I mean everything is
part of the machine I mean but we may
love these stories we may love these
characters but they are soap operas sold
to us on paper by Corporation yes but
they are selling a story ah anyway my
point is they're selling US stories but
there's they're like okay it's not
enough that we're we're selling these
stories but like we have an agenda we
got to sell these specific characters
because Chris Evans wants to be a
director now and he doesn't want to be
Captain America anymore what the hell
are we gonna do like yeah I do find that
funny though it's almost like Marvel and
even Disney were like oh this will never
end they'll never want to stop being
these superheroes oh yeah will never get
into a car accident or
something well all right
here be I'm just saying like wow you
jinxed the hell out of if that happens
next week s oh you were so dead if that
blow up actually no that joke's too dark
never
mind but like can you imagine the people
when they were making Empire Strikes
like before they were like we're gonna
make Empire Strikes Back oh my God Luke
Skywalker is in a horrible car accident
what are we going to do say he got hit
by a
wamp and they did and he did and by the
way Marvel is like against inity for
that those like Natalie Portman probably
would love to Play
Thor could you imagine that come over
here for a second Thor Ragnarok Midway
through the movie there's a swap out the
hammer drops and she's like oh [__]
right oh dude dude I've been dude no
I've been telling people I've been
telling people that forever with Jane
Foster like like she's going to pick up
the hammer at some point like I've been
saying that forever like like th's gonna
get out of bed you know and he's gonna
be like I need to go do some fighting
and stuff she's gonna be like well don't
forget your Hammer she's gonna it
to like really weird about like all
right well we've been talking for about
30 minutes about Marvel Comics before we
shift over to the trailers and the TV
shows let has anything been happening in
DC that I've been missing because I'm
not even lie I was thinking about this
last week CU I'm a huge DC fan that
everyone knows that but for the last two
months like I've like not been given a
crap outside of the Batman Bloom
storyline Dark Side war is really all I
mean I thought dark side Dark Side War
has been good
but the thing like I was I was so like
on board for Dark Side War stuff but
there's been a drought in stuff going on
I I know this is going to shock everyone
but um I think Titans Hunt is really
goodly [__] a good F shocker I agree
with you f even if I think they're kind
of you know uh spinning their wheels for
a little bit in the last issue it's just
like come on we're five issues everyone
get together now every everyone get
together they're not together yet no
they're not no no they're not like okay
I'm like this this premise is amazing
and then I'm like watching it I'm like
this is awesome this is awesome what
what okay this is do it do
it I just I feel like that's just
classic British writers like just keep
the group apart for as long
as we drag out this little tidbit
probably only got culture like it's it's
it's it all goes all the way back to
Dickens when who was paid by the word
they're like no no no you got to stretch
it out or you you won't get a big enough
check no dude you they sold by the issue
now now perhaps the biggest Revelation
from Titans Hunt is Dick Grayson put his
Nightwing costume on again yay but it's
the crappy red one boo you had a chance
I like I always like the red one think
that's the biggest thing other than dark
side War what is it now the Revelation
out of Robin War oh I have was a
terrible story it was a stinker and
guess I picked up Damien this week which
everyone's like oh it's the Fallout
issue you see what happens it's
literally a whole issue where Damen Gets
a Haircut and tells Alfred a [__]
story no you're right 100% right the
Fallout issue is not there yet I think
they're waiting to tie it into Bruce's
return which is in two issues now um but
Robin war was not that bad I mean oh my
God it was I did seven solid minutes I
Lincoln March is the villain even though
he has no reason for the court to trust
him his plan is stupid everyone turns
evil then turns back for no reason and
then at the end everyone forgives dick
for being a jerk it's like oh we got to
forgive you then okay but likes you why
do you get a poke holes in it I actually
liked it I I don't know like I mean I
I'll check I mean it's check it out
because there there's mix what about the
fact that they build up these Elite
talents which is a stupid idea to create
a subsect for a group of enemies who are
already incredibly difficult to defeat
and they get beaten at the End by cops
and untrained freaking Sidekicks and
also Duke the chosen one can we talk
about this Duke goes mono Mano with
Damian at the end what like I like Duke
don't get me wrong but he should not
have been able to win that fight when uh
Tim and Jason get one punched by Daman
and are out for the rest of the comic
yeah wow so uh wow weaving at Joel
rant what about about Dick Grayson being
on the court of the AL now I mean but he
was already being a sleeper agent
undercover dude for spiral so now he's
like being two undercover sleeper agents
and two or he's a triple agent now
that's cool what's cooler than a double
agent a triple agent well the coolest
part about it is though like Everyone
likes the secret agent thing right no no
no no Everyone likes the secret agent
thing right no everyone let's do triple
let's sure I like the secret agent thing
I might be the only one who likes it dig
it people dig it but it's like would you
like the secret agent thing or him being
Nightwing yeah that's the thing it only
works because people like Dick Grayson
okay I've said it in one of in I think
three of my videos now actually I'll say
it again # bring back the
butt
yeah just do it do that and F will be
happy if you've got the choice of making
him Nightwing which would have worked at
the end of that storyline just by
tweaking a thing here or there or making
him a secret agent [__] make him
Nightwing again because Nightwing is
going to sell a whole lot more than
Grayson ever will I would agree with
that no I agree Grayson's actually a fun
book but I if I had to pick one of the
other I would yeah give me Nightwing
back well because I mean it's just like
a giant Nostalgia trip I mean everybody
everybody like oh my God Nightwing you
know that's that's the character that I
know like's cool but it's make him move
back to blood Haven because we've
already established in Detective Comics
that blood Haven exists in the new 52
it's where Rene Montoya was hiding at so
make him Nightwing make him be blue and
then send him back to blood Haven make
him make him the way he used to be in
the night even if we just got like a
spin-off Series where he's disco
Nightwing for a little
bit just yeah or any like you got the
DCU still going on you got like three
different Batman in four different
universes like how about just make him a
Nightwing in one of the other universes
like how about just like dark side
Warrior's Nightwing or in freaking
Justice League of America Nightwing
whatever just pick one and make one just
do like a night do like a Nightwing
Earth one story
is except except Batman's barely become
Batman in Earth
one
like the last thing that Earth One
Batman needs is to be in charge of a
child notman but this one Earth One
Batman is awesome though but he is
awesome but he's prone to Falling like a
lot dude I I really I really want to
start making videos on the earth one
series because I've been reading those
and they are so I'm waiting for a few
more to come out I'm doing the same
thing but I'm waiting for just a few
more yeah the ones that are great
Superman Batman uh that that Teen Titans
one I enjoyed the Titans the teenage the
teenage Titans I like it because I like
lamir it had nothing to do with Titans
it was basically his spec script for a
movie he was working
on but it's coming out with those
previews are like uh oh dude I've never
read I've never really read like Teenage
mut ninja Titans but I always thought
they'd be pretty
B because that Earth One Wonder Woman
book looks like uh looks like there's a
lot of like per like weird creepy
permissive rape in it and stuff it's
just I as much [__] as I give you for
liking Grant Morrison V I do like Grant
Morrison's writing only thing I will say
and I don't care what you say chat
multiversity makes no goddamn sense oh
my God
no no you know what you know what
everybody get
out okay I liked Pax Americana I like a
lot I like that one um I am foreign so
what I'm about to say is okay uh I I I I
different uneducated Americans so what
what you I liked multiversity
because I like weird stuff okay I like
stuff that most people would cons would
say oh that doesn't make sense and I've
got to sit there thinking about it for
the next 20 20 days I'm still thinking
about multiversity and so I absolutely
love it the opened with an open hand but
the villain had a closed hand you get it
he's anti-life he's a closed hand not an
open hand you know what here's here's
here's what drove here's what drove me
nuts about M about multiversity oh my
God besides so I was I was sitting here
last night and I was like you know what
I want to do a video just explaining the
new 52 Multiverse making likeing sense
of it all you know how does the
Multiverse shape up how's all that stuff
work I thought it'd be fun so I was like
gr Morrison's gr Morrison's got a map on
the Multiverse right like let's just
look up let's look up the map on the
Multiverse and so I'm sitting there
looking at that I'm like okay the source
I understand that it's it's like God you
know and then you got the sth wall which
is like a it's like it's do what well I
said well because there's also the over
monitor well that's dude that's the
problem man is
called dud dude I called dude I called
uh called Joel and I was like all right
dude like you got to help me with this I
was like so I'm looking at this you got
the source you got the over Monitor and
then you got the monitor's fear but all
the monitors died out in final like a
final crisis and he was like uh yeah I'm
like so is this new 52 he's like well
well you know it could be like it
depends because the monitors show up in
multiversity you see at least one in a
shadow thing so here's the problem is if
he gives us a map and says hey guys
here's a map of the Multiverse of the
new 52 and it has a new 52 world and it
has crime syndicate and it has all these
worlds and then he says but there's also
a monitor and multiversity somewhere as
far as I know the monitors are
multiversal so they're not in I can
explain that map right now um Grant
Morrison wanted the map of the
Multiverse to be right after final
crisis yes DC well I DC kept putting
multiversity on hold because it was
finished years ago exactly he'd been
working on for a while um it was
finished years ago it was supposed to be
published after my final crisis it only
just got into publishing um
after and then DC were like well we're
going to just change your map of the
Multiverse but don't change your story
we'll just change this map to go which
is why oh my God F you
are you I don't know why I didn't call
you earlier you are you are my man I
will buy you I will buy you dinner or
some [__] when we're in Wonder I'll buy
you the steak the code no you don't you
don't eat salad foods do you I'll buy
you a smoothie
[Laughter]
somewhere no look multiv had a great
idea I just feel like it was dragged out
just unbelievably stupidly for no reason
no the story just like gr Morrison can
be like look at this really convoluted
story that I've made like because I get
it I understand multiversity I don't
understand why it had to be dragged out
the way it did it depends how much of a
boner you have for weird else World
story because it's like hey here's the
Watchman but if it was told today and
told with the actual Charleston
characters not the standin that Alan
Moore had to create hey here's here's
thunderworld you know here's like an
actual Captain Marvel Mar story where
he's called Captain Marvel and here's
Nazi world that's fun well see was here
was a when it came to like here's a
kicker when it came to the multiversity
stories like the map is what threw me
off the stories made sense I found it
easier to understand multiversity if you
didn't look at it as like one ongoing
story but just looked at it as like a
series of individual stories that's what
you were supposed to look at as you were
supposed to the gr Morrison being
[__] you were supposed to look at it
as how one story can be told thousands
of ways and how sometimes one story can
be turned into loads of tiny little
stories Doc Savage Justice I like the
tiny little ones and I was on board
until they started heavily crossing over
and it's like oh well if you had paid
attention in issue two it Le leaked back
to this and I'm like no this made more
this was more fun when it was just
Multiverse stories like oh Nazis oh a
world where everyone's a a Teen Idol you
know that kind of thing and Dr sabana
Who crosses over and there's like a
different version of him in every world
savan I like that all right well let's
now now we're talking about stories from
like months ago so all right so I'm
going to up by bringing you guys your
Indie book of the day everyone needs to
go check out super zero I was just
telling these guys about it it's brought
to you by Aftershock which is Amanda
Connor and Jimmy pal say
it he's got such a cool last name I love
know I can't even say it but it's a
great girl that seems to be in a world
like ours today and how she wants to be
a superhero so like issue one she tries
to rig up parents getting mugged so that
she could recreate Batman's origin she
she sets her parents up to get mugged oh
I did I put a on my Instagram it's
amazing and then issue two which just
came out Wednesday she's uh she's trying
spiders yeah she no she she wants to get
bitten by radio actor spider so she
without spoiling it for you it's not
spiders but she does get bit that that
sounds awesome I need to check that out
now this this book is from palotti and
Connor's new comic company they started
After Shock comics of which they're
going to be having a bunch of of new
books out soon uh they're they're a cool
couple if you like the Harley Quinn book
if you like their old Power Girl run and
everything this is this is more of their
brand of wackiness yeah yeah no exactly
and it's it's awesome I love it so far
it does the back of every issue feature
another Aftershock comic so you can kind
of like Get Behind smart um but I
grabbed them both doing like the Valiant
thing yeah no exactly it's it's great if
you're looking for a story that isn't
like our usual DC Marvel discussions
check out superzero by Aftershock I just
wanted to let everyone know that one
that sounds awesome can I let everyone
know about something real quick do it
yeah no I I want you guys each to have a
recommendation that isn't our usual okay
suck so uh Europe finally has our own
answer to the Marvel and DC universes
it's coming in the form of something
called the Quantic Universe um there is
currently only one thing out from it and
it's not a comic it's a cartoon uh but
it's getting a comic apparently and it's
called Uh miraculous ladybug and it's
it's brilliant it's a French cartoon but
it's dubbed in English it's on Nickel in
America and it's basically supposed to
be like this teenage girl that works
with a superhero guy called shua and the
only way to describe it is they're
Western superheroes with Japanese Powers
oh so they're like what's happening to
me why am I being chased by a ghost what
are with these speed lines Why when
someone says something awkward do I fall
over why do when I get a little bit of
warm water on me I turn into a girl
bear what wh why do I get
no that's a Ramen
reference RMA is amazing I don't know
what you're talking about I would love
to be able to turn into a real all 35
years worth of RMA
Comics um what was the name of that one
F so I can link that also um miraculous
ladybug because I'm trying to link these
in as we do as we talk about them also
so they can click it
cool uh you're you're link me the thing
for Comics Al I can't find it oh it's
the comic isn't out yet it's a cartoon
at the
moment was gr Mor voice that's me was it
a cartoon that was a little hard that
was a little hard race for so let's go
ahead and talk about something else I go
pee
right oh God what Jess Jones season two
yeah yeah Jessica Jones season two it's
amazing and I'm happy I'm glad to see it
succeed I really hope they don't rush to
make her pregnant because let's face it
after you've tapped Alias for all of its
material you really only got a couple
places left the exact same thing I
guarantee you that will be the
opening thing her bir she'll be pregnant
episode one season two she'll be like
heaving into a toilet and she'll be like
these this morning sickness is really
killing me and she hasn't called Luke
and that'll be like the union between
her and Luke will be like I got your
baby inside me he's like well sweet
Christmas I got to get I got to step up
man like well cuz you've also got the
option of like if Inhumans are
introduced into the Marvel Universe by
this point maybe there's a girl that's
an inhuman that's gone missing and the
whole story line could be that Jessica
needs to find her I mean there are
couple stories you could do yeah we have
not run out of Alias books yet like
there
are although they did use the big
overarching purple man thing and they
could and they could reintroduce or they
could introduce Jessica Drew into the
Marvel Cinematic Universe and have that
brilliant part where she calls Jessica
Jones [__] tits dude that was H down
for that I appreciate that um there well
see I was thinking the same thing that
like Joel was because I was I was they
were like Jessica Jones season 2 and I
was like well purple man was likeing a
lot of water because I'm sick oh and I
was I was like purple man was like The
Last Arc of the Alias series yes and
basically everything else in the show
covered Alias so I was like where are
they going to was actually a really
hilarious thing there was when they did
the whole announcement thing like
somebody had sent a tweet or I don't
know if they sent a tweet to me or
somebody else but just happened to see
it on Twitter and they were like do you
think purple man will be in season two
and I'm like did you see season
one pretty sure not coming back then
again there's always the nuke well they
could tap if that wanted to be the thing
like Jessica investigating that super
soldier company dude that'd be so
awesome if they gave
nuke season two is going to be what
episode one is going to be civil war
starting and her going to Canada episode
two is going to be another incident
happening she's going to leave episode
three will be another situation where
she has to leave um episode four Luke
Cage is gonna show up and be like oh my
God uh Spider-Man's being attacked by
Daredevil and she be like all right
let's get the hell out of here we're out
you know episode five will begin their
move where they're going to move across
the country to LA because they can't
stay in New York anymore at this point
oh can you blame them dude I don't know
if' be family drama I don't know if
you've seen Shameless but think
Shameless I've seen wow I mean Jessica
Jones constantly leaving places is the
reason why I say if there was a weekly
pool Civil War I'd be Jessica Jones and
take
off things things are getting too hot I
don't want to jeopardize my baby season
two the road
trip unless unless of course like Jarvis
just like kidnaps your child oh no oh
God secret Invasion okay so what what do
you guys think of Legends of tomorrow
know you all of you must have seen it I
haven't seen it yet actually I've seen
it then [__] you okay you're you're
awesome although although can I get away
with not seeing it because it's not on
TV in the UK at the moment oh yes I will
give you a pseudo [__] you it's a [__]
it's a [__] off UK like with a caveat on
it little thing I I enjoyed it I thought
it was a shaky start mainly because they
had to regress a lot of characters to
heighten drama like now Firestorm is
fighting when they weren't before the
Hawks aren't getting along even though
they were before do Dr Stein does a real
dick move real early on and basically
really does he roofies his partner and
takes him on a time travel mission where
it's like dude I will also for a time
travel show you you got to do this right
away and they didn't do it they haven't
hammered home the time travel rules that
we're working and that's a bad move when
you're doing a show about time well not
not unless you're just going to play by
ear makeup rules is to go along I
feel I feel like this is CW's attempt to
make their show less
CW yes oh very much so it's can we try a
12 to 13 right to the point series
instead of 22 Episodes and this one
Barry's going to go get upset about
something and run off into a completely
side plot and you know I feel like
that's what this is an attempt at but to
take a Netflix Style Show and put it
serialized on a normal Network yeah
night you know also to at nine people
because Firestorm is Tech technically
two people and we got Captain Cold and
Heatwave even though you already have a
fire guy so why do you have another fire
guy that's a big that's oh yeah he's the
comic relief he's the big dumb funny guy
he's Drax he is this team's Drax is what
he is he says dumb funny things which I
like he does a great job don't get me
wrong but nine people is a lot of
characters you know you know it's a show
that everyone loves that had nine
characters nine fully rounded characters
902 Firefly you know that show called
friends they had a lot of
show yeah it had firly friends a lot in
common there and for the record I do
like the idea that we may not use
everyone every episode because like
about they like oh we have a purpose for
you guys and that makes more sense than
being like here's rip Hunter traveling
through time with his
Entourage that would be a little that
would be it's totally a rip Hunter show
is the thing it is his story he is the
main character that's the thing which is
fine because he's a good actor and I
think he does a good job and I think Ray
Palmer is going to get become like the
star because they definitely put a lot
of focus on Ray Palmer yes they did he
gave an he gave an amazing speech Ray
Palmer he's like man it's just it's just
like I'm never living up to people's you
know uh you know I'm just never living
up to it I'm like yeah you were supposed
to be Superman and you didn't live up to
it I he was one of the best Superman he
was so good I don't know if he was one
of the best Superman but he was good he
was great I would love to see him he
didn't get his chance I'll say that much
he got he had no chance for me to be a
huge fan super well okay I I will say
his portrayal of Superman wasn't bad it
was just the movie wasn't written that
well it
just that movie be would be great if
there wasn't a kid in it I know it's
only been a day but did anyone watch
Lucifer no no no I I mean I do need to
but I was traveling because I I was is
it Hulu F I'm just letting you
know
also
noad Lucifer if you like vertico stuff
watch it just to make make them make
more vertigo TV okay I will I will I
will say this when I was going through
and making my video on the presents I
had to dive into a bunch of that vertigo
stuff because that's like where all the
religious context things are oh yeah and
and it was it actually wasn't bad like
it was actually pretty cool like a lot
of
that all that kind it was it was
actually it was pretty interesting it
was it was weird to wrap my head around
to go because it's such a huge
distinction to go from like superheroes
like Superman to like Lucifer war star
and like I'm waging a war against God
like it was It was a it was kind of a
weird thing to wrap my head around but
once you got past that it was it was
pretty enjoyable I mean that's the big
issue like that the new 52 is still
struggling with is that the vertigo
Universe was like separated from the DC
Universe like they would sometimes cross
but was like there was no real reason to
let
make like Swamp Thing was mostly
vertigo unless they wanted Batman to
show up and those those were good books
those were great runs that they just
could do anything with I mean I mean
people forget Snider wrote the first
couple volumes of Swamp Thing when it
started it was amazing it was it's run
into rot world oh my god oh yeah I I
have the collection it's good stuff it's
good stuff that DC just did not
capitalize it's funny I read the new
poison ivy book this week and she
mentions the green and I'm like oh yeah
that cool idea you brought up in Swamp
Thing They never did anything with
that's isn't that why they Chang no they
used it again in Justice League
Unlimited where she showed up and like
they're like we needed someone attached
to the green and she's like you brought
swamping he is the
green didn't they yeah didn't they like
when the new started they made Beast Boy
red because they wanted him connected to
the red and then they just changed it
and then they just changed him to Green
gave got an explanation as to why um but
yeah no so anyway um yeah so I guess
back on back to TV shows tomorrow shaky
start I'm interested to keep up with it
did anyone else catch all the Doctor Who
things they're doing there rip Hunter
works for the time I mean Masters and he
has the wave I mean the [__] I mean the
Wave
Rider Wave Riders thing I will I will
say this because I want to throw this
out there because I mean I haven't seen
Legends of the tomorrow but having taken
so long of a break from The Flash and in
h Arrow um when they came back on I sat
them down like I sat down and watched
them back to back and I got to tell you
like I don't like Arrow as much as I
like flash like flash is Flash is fun
superher dude it's so much
superhero show with a dude who doese all
the time it's actually somewhat true to
the source material unlike Arrow like
okay how are we going to make Poor Man's
Batman today no it's it's not it's not
that it's not that arrow is not true to
the source material that bothers me it's
just like I watched that show and it's
like man I'm depressed like God I'm just
sad you know like when I when I watch I
got watch the season the season premier
back because I got I gotta play catchup
I gota watch that xfiles Lucifer I want
watch I need to watch x I haven't seen X
and I guess I guess Heroes is done now
too hero over Dude I I have watched
again surprisingly right you know this
is my shock face that Heroes didn't make
it yeah okay you know what they came out
they get renewed no no it's canel can D
that was a great season I I haven't seen
the finale yet but I loved it I got I
got bored to be honest like I I I lost
interest in it and it wasn't because it
was well it wasn't because the the
concept was bad the concept was actually
pretty cool but the issue was that the
characters just weren't that interesting
to me you know yeah they weren't as good
as the the last season so so okay well
we're running a low on time so let's
move on to the Suicide Squad trailer I
like that man I am hyped yeah the only
thing I did I I will say this I I SP I
would be upset if they didn't do the
Harley Quinn High pissed voice but after
hearing Margaret Robbie doing it I'm
like I like she makes it her own she
makes it her own she does her own which
I appreciate her not just
doing but the fact is like she did she
did it already in Wolf of Wall Street
she sounds like Harley Quinn and they
it's like I was like oh they cast her
because she did such an amazing like
kind of like New York
accent God Mr bord boy God with all your
money and all your drugs like oh my God
she freaking Nails in that movie and
then you cast the chick at the movie and
just do this stupid voice I'm like all
right fine she said in different
interviews that her goal was to not copy
like the whole Paul De Harley Quinn
thing and she she wanted to make like
she wanted she wanted the Harley Quinn
that she had in the film to stand on her
own but also she wanted her to be crazy
so it looks like we're going to get you
know a pretty good Robie Holly Quinn
that's crazy having having said that
having said that in my video on on the
on Marvel films like I I called it like
I think that Suicide Squad is gonna be
one of the standout movies of this year
I think it might do better than Batman v
Superman as weird as that sounds I don't
I don't know if it I I don't know if
it'll make more money but I think more
popular I proce being one of the highest
grossing like on that list of highest
grossing films and even if it sucks in
bombs I see it making
that be one of the biggest movies of the
year no question Batman vers super but I
think I think Suicide Squad is going to
because it's so different like me and me
and Joel talked about this last time
like like all the other movies are you
know with the exception of Deadpool it's
like Heroes being Heroes like with
Suicide Squad it's villains being
Heroes and it's new and it's characters
a lot of people haven't seen before like
people have seen Batman people have seen
Superman maybe not not Deadshot
yeah you would you would have no reason
to see Deadshot outside of a Suicide
Squad movie so through Captain Boomerang
and Deadshot have both been on the TV
shows but whatever yeah oh yeah Deadshot
was on he was on a and then they buried
the suicide squad on that show cuz
they're like no no no we're we're making
a movie no more for you well but yeah
but they also that now they're like oh
no you could use them on the TV shows
again like that well that's because they
want to build up they want to build up
popularity for the movie the name the
name Suicide Squad be for me how much
cuz like this trailer was solid and the
charact the movie looks really cool
really dark but like fun and cool neon
very like 80s Noir almost right flashing
lights for me how much more awesome
would it have been if man of steelbatman
mov if those movies were more superh
heroic like if directed by air like what
if a was the architect of this new D I
was gonna say like what if like Superman
Returns was the Man of Steel Superman
movie and then they made this Suicide
Squad where it's like you go Superman
yay hooray he was my dad did not jump
into a tornado but but then you do
Suicide Squad so you're like and and
you're like whoa whoa whoa this is the
same freaking Universe like suicide
squad being in the man of St Universe
yeah no crap they're in the same
universe everyone's unhappy but like if
you made a superhero movie where
Superman's like a hero and exciting and
and bright and happy and then you make
Suicide Squad it just makes it that much
more what the crap people are watching
that people would just go into that
movie without even knowing that they're
connected and then they then they go
like that flying guy and like whoa you
mean they're all in the same universe
like that would be such a cool mind F
it's it's funny s you say that the
suicide squad guys aren't happy I feel
the op I think they're having a freaking
ball
honestly more fun how sick is that that
I would rather hang out with the suicide
squad than the Justice Le I me I
probably wouldn't last long hanging with
the suicide squad I'd probably be
stabbed and thr I'd play a game of one
thing on the new Justice Batman versus
Superman teaser Superman batting the
Batmobile come
on I'm not I'm not saying it's not to I
will say the dialogue in that scene was
real bad do you bleed B well you
will but then the next scene because
they released another scene with with
Batman and Alfred being like and
Alfred's like you're gonna fight the god
in the sky and he's like he killed
thousands of that scene totally okay I'm
like oh crap the dialogue is a little
better than this scene okay oh dude like
I'm know what to think like I was I was
looking at that and and it's funny
because when you go back and you look at
the trailer it's like I can't help but
compare like the scenes as they go
through in terms of like you know how
they Rel late I think the whole Ben
Affleck uh Jeremy Irons is going to like
Stand Out the movie more so than
anything else but I will say this about
suicide squad going through and looking
at the trailer that movie looks like
it'll feel a lot like Watchmen like when
I was going through and watch it has
like a Watchman look and feel to it
which I I got a very Guardian vibe off
it yeah a guardian a guardian five I got
a very Guardians like the bit where like
Rick flag is like he's a crocodile man
he shoots people yeah I think that
Suicide Squad is absolutely going to be
DC's guard even the choice of Music
which by God when you get fraking Queen
one of that was so cool when you get one
of the greatest songs ever written to
underscore your trailer you you get like
five extra points from Joels dude I love
Bohemian RS and it makes sense
thematically the song Because what words
keep getting used over and over will not
let you go will not let you go because
they're prisoners yeah now all right
here's here's what I'm here's here's and
this I think I think I think DC is
playing it smart by like keeping a lot
of this hidden but like Jared Leto's
joker now here's here's the funny thing
is we know Joker is going to be in The
Suicide Squad but as far as I count
they've only released maybe three clips
of him as the Joker across all the
trailers that have come out and to me
that is so smart and I think they I
think they did that no no no no I think
I think that's smart because Joker's
going to be the attraction and I think
that they're playing off the Batman and
the Superman Fallout and here's the
reason why because people came out and
they were like Batman versus Superman
just show too much and I'm not even sure
I want to go see it now but people are
just like I wonder how Jared Leto is
going to be as the Joker and the shots
we got in the trailer of Joker he's
clearly in this movie a lot more than
people might have thought yeah because
he's in like three or four different
scenes three or four different costume
changes three or four different total
settings Joker's a main player and yet
to what capacity we are still not sure
we're not even really sure who the
villain of The Suicide
Squad what if they're chasing him down
that's freak Co there's that and then in
the trailer you see some weird Vine
monster dude messing stuff up which
everyone's like is that omac is that
like some weird new movie version of
omac well here's here's a question that
I have because I don't know if they've
released that is it oh it's man thing
it's the dimensional the dimensional
portals like would wouldn't that
wouldn't that be hilarious if they had
man thing and they were just like this
guy like all you have to do is go to the
Flor to Everglades and you guys get to
Crossover with Marvel like but uh
they're clearly fighting something
magical is the thing in the trailer
there's clearly some sort of
Otherworldly force that they're fighting
enchantress and that too there's a lot
of talk that enchantress is actually a
double agent because in the bigger group
shots you don't see
enchantress I think she just dies in the
beginning that's my thought process
behind that the suicide squad is known
for every run hey who's going to die I
keep I keep thinking about that like who
is going to die now here oh it's it's
it's slip knot and I'll tell you why
it's slip knot cuz you barely see him in
the trailer Adam Beach is a kind of
well-known character actor who'd be
willing to take a paycheck and also if
you read OST strangers uh run with slit
knot in it he's the guy who's like I
don't need this Suicide Squad runs away
gets his arm blown off W so he's gonna
be that guy he's gonna be the guy
Waller's like I'm not messing around
you're dead here's here's something else
that I saw too like I was looking
looking through one of the trailers and
there's a scene where it looks like
Harley Quinn's being dipped on the whole
acid thing that the Joker was supposed
to and here's here's my question is is
that before or after because you know
like is the Harley Quinn that we see
because Margot Robbie's like really pale
but my question is is she pale because
she's not ghostly my question is that is
that like does she make herself look
that way until she meets The Joker and
then she joins him like gets dipped in
the whole chemical bath we clearly see
them driving around Bonnie and Clyde
style when that man hops on their purple
Lambo and stops their Natural Born
Killer spree here's my question about
that just just a just being nerd is it
going to be Batman or is it going to be
a stunt double that never says anything
like is it going to be is did they get
Ben AFF like on the said wouldn't that
be cool or is it just gonna be it's just
gonna be Batman on the roof and then he
gets thrown off and that's the end let
me let me let me tell you something if
they did that if if in the movie like
like Batman tries to stop him and it's
been Affleck for like three or four
minutes they're they're up in points on
Marvel right off the bat because that's
awesome here's the thing they they
filmed those scenes in Toronto and a
bunch of footage leaked out and like I
know some people who went down to watch
it I don't think Affleck was there oh
really I don't think Affleck they might
that doesn't mean that the stun double
wasn't there for the stunt scene and
they're affle scenes
later against Green closeups whoa I'm on
a
car think Ben Affleck's gonna hang on to
a car as they hold TI Ben we can't have
you fall at off people are saying people
are saying Ben Affleck is like he is in
the movie oh I mean I don't doubt he's
in the movie but is he in that scene
yeah well okay I mean no I don't mean
the movie is like a that's the movie I'm
thinking about that
scene I mean he'll probably be post
credit or something or you know yeah man
like I'm waiting for the dark side post
credit scene you guys saw that leak oh
yeah dark yeah dark side or dark side
yeah oh okay is anyone surprised at this
point I didn't think about that like
somebody I was looking at the trailer
and somebody had mentioned the
parademons and I was like what and I
went back and I was like those are
paradons and so I was like
well they wouldn't be the wicked witches
flying oh you're talking about like that
scene with the Superman Squad and Batman
and like the duster and stuff that's a
nightmare we know what that is they've
already spoiled it but hey just because
it's a nightmare doesn't mean those
still aren't parad demons in his night
true they're definitely parad demons
well parad demons those are
paradons I mean I was it's not a
nightmare then maybe it's a vision that
got beamed no it's not a vision it's
just a from the new Gods we we'll just
throw everything into this movie it's
only what two hours long like oh my God
this mov this movie is gonna be filled
with the bra someone tweeted out someone
tweeted out they were like just make it
three and a half hours put it all in
there we don't care I will watch a three
and a half hour long Justice League
movie me too but but you know they
trimmed it down from a lean six though
is the thing to a to it it's like
freaking made in America or something it
was a sixh hour cup we'll never see
until years later they Tri it down to a
lean all right so with us running out of
time let's go over the couple last
tidbits they put out uh Wonder Woman
movie uh Chris Pine Pang playing Colonel
Trevor World War II piece apparently no
World War I one yeah how does that even
work the movie is going to be a World
War I film yes it is and it work it's
World War I to help differentiate us
from that other World War II here you
see there's a certain Shield holding guy
who kind of has World War II on
lockdown here's the question I've never
known Wonder Woman to just be
old I mean apparently she's supposed to
be like 5,000 years old I did not I did
not get that impression ever but no
that's not her that she's I got the
impression she's fairly new yeah like
she grows like a regular human being I
think they're gonna do that I think
they're gonna be like yeah no no no
she's like hund she's like hundreds
years old well yeah I mean if she's made
of clay or a demigod why would why would
she I mean you could yeah you could get
away with it she's Zeus's daughter she's
made of clay like there's a number of
reasons why that can work yeah they
could easily just say whatever whatever
she's old or maybe they just freeze her
in ice she wakes up somebody that's a
great idea oh you can end the movie The
First movie she's on like a b plane
everybody andash in the Arctic oh wait a
minute that sounds familiar I forget it
what do you guys think about the flash
as M Flash costume I actually think it
looks kind of I know people are a Power
Ranger people are freaking out they like
man you would
not as Benny pointed out to me his
lightning bolts actually going the wrong
way and I didn't pick that up until he
told me I'm like whoa it is that kind of
stuff doesn't that kind of stuff doesn't
matter to me man his his flash symbols
back okay but no can you imagine if the
Superman symbol was backwards then you'd
be Bizarro yeah but flash flash is not
Superman well that's actually what
people are say is that reverse is that
reverse flash like reverse
flash okay what about what about them
putting in cyborg but no Green Lantern
on that Cameo post that don't Green
Lantern doesn't get a movie until 2020
he did a bad bad thing and so he's got
to wait the dog house they're waiting
for he wiped out the you know what they
should do like here I'll be 100% honest
with you guys they need to do that they
need to wait till Ryan Reynolds finishes
Deadpool or once once he's out of
whatever it is he's doing next and be
like dude come play Green Lantern again
he had a shot no he was he was not a bad
Hal Jordan the problem is the writing
for H Jordan was bad the the movie
writing was bad make it John Stewart
please I I agree John would be cool but
mym Jord he's not doing anything right
now dude Michael
Jordan
go I'm sorry I'm sorry for interrupting
F go ahead my criticism of his of him is
he plays the same character in every no
he
doesn't he's Van Wilder across the world
no he's not yeah he is don't forget I'm
the only one here that's actually seen
any of Deadpool so I will say he play
the same
character a Deadpool costume oh uh the
remake of Amityville Horror or whatever
oh yeah that was cool that's right he
did an okay job in that
but
like he saw Jason Le Ms and he's like
that I'm going to do that until the end
of time that's he also played guy in the
crudes if anyone ever saw that no but I
do remember I do remember he was on 15
and he played a very some very dramatic
scenes in that show when he was when he
was like was also in when he was like 12
years old like whatever I can't remember
the movie it's that movie with Sandra
bolock I was like oh he was he also
shows up in Ted and doesn't say anything
oh sweet oh you're you're talking about
the proposal The Proposal yeah which is
that amazing a hilarious romcom a
delicious that movie that movie is
hilarious man The Proposal know anything
else though on the DC thing I can't
remember because I didn't get to see it
live uh uh they were they were talking
about like Killer Frost and Firestorm
showing up from Earth to which actually
Death Storm he's Death Storm the other
Universe costume is cooler than the
other costume dude it's TV show yeah the
TV show D it looks cool man like they
say it's supposed to be like they're
supposed to have a whole Bonnie and
Clyde feel and I'm actually really hyped
about that
I'm really looking for Ronnie AEL gets
to come back so he's probably happy
about that okay you know what here's
here's the thing you know I liked Ronnie
AEL and I felt like they really did him
a disservice by cutting his character
off so fast I kept thinking they were
GNA find him again like oh he's just
lost in the univers and he's because if
you remember in the early promotion
teaser trailer for Legends of tomorrow
it was Ronnie standing there not Jax
they reshot that and put Jax back in
there it was supposed to be Ronnie I
have a feeling Ronnie backed out of his
contract because he's in another show
now oh really so I have a feeling he was
signed on for all that crap and there
someone else offered more money well
because that Adam costume was like no
all right I'm gonna do a show well see
like I it seems like it seems like a
show I don't know it seems like with a
show like The Flash it's like working
anywhere in Kentucky where like you get
hired on and then you have to like
murder a person to be fired and so I
feel like like once the guy hired on
like he was just going to be there for
the rest of life or until he decided to
leave and so like that's that's why you
know it's it makes sense that he would
back out of his contract but if he did
that's kind of disappointing because he
was a really good Firestorm I lik him
but then again I like the new guy too
Jax has a weird kind of Charisma to him
in the last uh episode he gave this
really cornball speech about teamwork
and what he learned playing football and
I'm like I should hate this but I kind
of like it I want to I want to throw
this out there too as a nerd I should be
against this but ex exactly well no my
my problem with with the Jack character
is why why the hell did we introduce
Raymond rush but not get him yeah we
introduced the other versions yeah the
irony being that Jax is actually a
character from Firestorm comics he was
he was like their buddy who was in the
background and he got like a major
promotion like hey now you get to be
Firestorm I now you get to be the lead
singer man you don't have to play backup
was oh Jason Jason Rush yeah so we we
had we had Ronnie and we had uh yeah we
had Jason yeah whatever why did we not
get the other guy we introduced maybe he
was busy maybe he had another show he
had to be on well they're setting him up
as a villain I think you're talking
about the guy that like are are you
talking okay I'm not not they brought in
and they were trying to make work that
was to there's a character named Jason
Rush he was actually the the actual in
the coms they were trying to get
information on The Firestorm Matrix
before Ronnie came back the whole thing
oh okay they saw him out and it was a
fun Easter egg yeah then they left it at
that then they just left it hanging
which which you're right is weird that
they left it um okay did you guys I
assume you guys super girl's not bad
screw you guys I I I assume you guys saw
this the whole Wally West thing yeah
they're doing the new 52 version where
he's kind of a punk and I don't know I'm
not sure how I feel about it and and I
feel dude I'm on the fence about that
for a couple reasons one like which that
bugged me that he's given Jo Joe didn't
know you existed until last week cut him
some slack well see that's that's why
I'm not sure that i' like it one like I
understand the whole the whole aspect of
his character of like you know my dad
didn't even know I existed and like I'm
just dealing with it and kind of angry
like I can understand that from the way
they're writing is character what I
don't like is he's just like The
Reckless I'm gonna go street race and I
showed up here I'm also Michael B Jordan
from the Fantastic exactly Street chip
on my shoulder I'm like really that's
that's I was looking at that and I was
like this the the whole thing felt so
forced and I get it's like a TV show but
it was it was it didn't feel like
organic like a TV show it just felt like
we've got to find a way to get Wally
West into this thing it doesn't feel
organic and what makes me feel sad too
is I'm sure at some point they had the
happy fun loving Wall-E on the table and
they're like but Cisco is our funny one
and we have lots of other funny
characters we can't have another funny
character let's make him yeah this isn't
a comedy this is a superhero here's the
other problem too is with them
introducing the new 52 Wally West my
question is where they going to go
because they've never done anything with
the new2 Wally West now they can do
whatever they want with and nerds like
us started com back recently recently
they started using him again but it
was we'll see what happened like I'm I
mean I just I did that video just for
the sake of having it there but I'm not
interested in that in that Wally I'm not
really even interested in the old Wally
West but like nonetheless you know I
think that having having that Wally West
on there is cool for the sake of tying
in the new 52 it's just they're
basically making up the source material
as they go along now right so they don't
which is what doing Legends of tomorrow
because they don't have 75
years we're just making up a team show
as we go along that's true which is fine
we we're coming to the end over here so
anybody have any parting thoughts on all
of this stuff uh I'll relay what Joel's
thinking [__] comic book ass but
anyway you brought it back you brought
it back full circle baby I had to I had
to also Peggy carard is a good show
season two is
when right they had two new episodes
they back to back a good thing they did
because when when did they Premiere week
same night as flash Tuesdays well then
I'm gonna have to look him up on Twitter
or on a Hulu because I didn't know they
I didn't know she came back already man
that's damn I wish I known that it was
fun it was very Sol oh dude I love
season one of Agent Carter it was
amazing way Shield yeah I wish I could
watch piggy Carter but dude watch it on
you have an internet connection we don't
have Hulu in the UK you Hulu to watch TV
shows you can't use Hulu in the UK why
I'm I'm not promoting it but maybe you
should torrent I'm not promoting
torrenting but maybe you should torrent
yeah I mean it's a thing that people do
everywhere you guys steal our shows then
send it to us it's true all right guys
well thank you guys all so much don't
forget I'm Benny the comic storian that
is s from comic pop that is Joel from
Cape Joel that is Rob from what actually
what what are you from what does
everybody have going on this week oh
yeah been a while
I videos Benny's just ready to get out
of here he's just like man I gotta go to
the bathroom you
guys I think I think I'm just gonna do
I'm I'm just gonna start Batman Earth
One whatever why not I dare you right I
dare you I also dare you to do a top 10
boobs of 2015 video don't do it I've
been there already well no like no like
like Goldman's banned for my channel so
it's not going to be that big of a deal
I could get away with
it you should do your top 10 man crushes
of 2015 top I I should I should do top
top five DC
boobs individual started individual the
left one on this character was in the
top 10 but the right one was like off
the problem Rob's gonna have run it run
into is just like really just 10 really
I can only pick 10 yeah man be rough
technically you can pick five every
set's got two ah so so by math what we
find out
is anyway what's what else is happening
uh well if you had on over to Cape Joel
new reviews every day now I'm trying out
a bunch of different stuff I should
hopefully have a new Rack Attack up by
the end of tonight and no that's not a
boob thing I mean I mean ra I mean rack
is in comic rack damn it is what I meant
best boobs on Rack
Attack it's just me sounds like horrible
horrible wrestling match T WWE it
actually is a wrestling move I kid you
not I've actually run into a lot of
problems with people searching it
because it actually is a ra it is a move
I mean there there are some really bad
wrestling shows it's called every
Monday that's a raw joke
everybody I'm sorry I'm really is there
really is the female Divas is doing the
Rack Attack it's Bri like finishing you
didn't know that I got watch wrestling
has sucked in the last 10 years yeah
it's not been good since like 19 I know
this is going to be a shock to all of
you but I have literally never been into
wrestling wow that's hard to imagine
actually that is shock assume you'd like
to see men walking around in underwear
but dumb Tish I mean I like that bab but
like they
actually um I guess on my channel this
week on uh we've got uh one year later a
new show I'm doing where we look at
movies um like one year after they're
out and we say Do they still hold up
that's cool yeah it's one year later
after this first one well one year since
I saw the
movie for everybody and then on Friday
we're doing the first movie stream where
I sort of Riff on a movie while watching
it and you can't see the movie while I'm
watching it because copyright but you
can hear me rip on it and press the play
button while I well if you C you'll do
better than Rob sitting there eating
watching Daredevil well that's because
your movie won't be 18 hours long I
don't I don't know I don't know what
talking about like there are no videos
then tag me hour trying to make
conversation but just like no man I'm
watching this stop talking the one
advantage I have over Rob is that I do
standup comedy no there's there no to
the to the best of the world's knowledge
there are currently no videos on my
channel to ever indicate that I had uh
watched
Netflix why do you guys bring that up
all the time can I just
say my favorite thing about Rob doing
that is that I was the one that
suggested that and I suggested it
sarcastically and then he did it and I
didn't stop him I like just like I
suggested the boob video sarcastically
and Rob was
like and it's one of my highest
performing videos which is probably why
I should do like a DC boobs video for
the heck of it just be like you know
what this one goes out to all you guys
who gave me [__] last time here's boobs
you should do it for Valentine's Day is
when you should put it up that should be
your special Valentine's Day video my
Valentine's Day video yeah what it
should
be over on 13 hour stream it was not bad
I had a great
time but I love how they have to word it
in I experienced the Rob dared yeah it's
not like it's not like I can hung out
with Rob like I hung out with Rob while
he was watching Dar like I experienced
it I love that comment I I saw it Rob
it's burned in my memory as if they were
like sh to chair I just remember the day
you did that me and C both popping in
and both being like what the [__] is he
thinking yeah it was like Rob invited us
over and then did
Shores whatever I was there was there
not that bad I remember I was just I got
home from like shopping in town and then
St right away Rob called me and I was
like oh you must have seen my tweet that
I just got home I was like hey what's up
and you're like hey I'm streaming
Daredevil and I was like really are you
sure I thought you should have done
actually now that I think about it Rob
you should have sifted through all the
video and then only kept the moments
that were freaking
and just put up the parts where like Rob
reacts to Daredevil and it's just all
the best parts where you're like what no
Kingpin there's the
suit like
just why couldn't why couldn't you have
come up with that idea I literally just
had that idea worry it's not like I was
sitting on it since it was deleted but
my God man that was that's a really
solid idea you know what I'm I'm going
do done that I'll have to my favorite
fit is when Rob
went I liked it when robed hear him
here's here's we need to do Rob from now
on everyone we're going to do this every
day at lunch we're all just gonna eat
lunch on the stream just just sit here
not talk to each other ston Silence no
music just order ribs and can I just say
there's a video's
your amazing there's already a video on
my vlogging Channel called KFC of f it's
me eating AFC in stock
silence it's a for it's a form of art
it's like that freaking Andy Warhol
video where he just eats a
[Laughter]
hamburger guys on that note we should
probably get
going so everyone you have a great day
we'll see you next week right here at
the same bat Time same bat channel uh in
in the words of the infamous Joel K
sucks
anyway we'll catch you guys later if you
guys are going to be around San Antonio
this
weekend doing panels and crap and hang
out with you guys if you're in San
Antonio so I come to pack prob buy you
ice
cream if you come down there Rob buy you
ice cream dude that was fun buying ice
cream for those two guys and hanging out
that was fun like I bought I bought ice
cream for two fans H out Rob will buy
you an ice cream cone it'll be it wasn't
an ice cream cone it was a bowl of ice
cream it was an ice cream cone they
didn't have can can I give everyone fair
warning and say that they all have to to
wonder con because I'm actually going to
be there uh that be well except Joel
and were invited so all except
half word all right that say what you
were doing s what's going on this week
oh back just hits 100 episodes nice
congratulations dude thank you are you
guys gonna do another live stream are
you gonna live stream this back issues
no you should D you should live stream
it should be like a four hour back
issues we should do that that'd be fun
we did it one time and it was very
successful but this is just no I just
wanted to make the the 100th episode
like an episode as opposed to like us
getting up to go to the bathroom and
like gimmick yeah yeah but it's it's
solid we're doing vinyl crisis awesome
nice out on Thursday check it out a good
one you guys did a video on Earth one
didn't you we did Earth One Batman
volumes one and two and Superman volume
one okay cool they were good awesome
found KFC has F linking it in the chat
watch Ser dud I really want to watch
that I want to watch that KFC and F on
that note guys everyone go watch F some
KFC give thats give it a like and we'll
see you next time right here on the
weekly pool peace byebye